foreign
[Music]
Mike Shinoda co-founded the band Linkin
Park One of the best-selling acts of the
21st century I don't know why it doesn't
even matter how hard she tried all My
First Beats were sampled off of vinyl
records lately he sold a lot of vinyl
records and he likes to buy them
no that's what I call Rock he's not
alone vinyl albums outsold CDs last year
for the first time since 1987 to the
tune of 1.2 billion dollars
in today's digital era people can hear
hundreds of millions of songs anywhere
and yet vinyl expensive immobile and
left for dead is booming
it was kind of like well yeah that's
never coming back I was wrong I didn't
foresee it no physical formats ever came
back
until this one did
here's why this antique format is coming
back both in spite of and because of the
digital Music Revolution
in the beginning of the beginning around
the very early part of the 20th century
there were wax cylinders that carried a
sound recording Thomas Edison
's to the masses eventually it used
discs like this
[Music]
this little black pellets are ultimately
melted down and it becomes a biscuit
that gets pressed into a record Mark
Michaels is the CEO and owner of the
largest press in America United record
pressing in Nashville
back in the 60s and 70s when vinyl was
really the only format that was was
relevant and it was the core existence
of United it was a very very busy place
but the format has its limitations and
you couldn't really listen to it on the
way to work or while you were doing
anything else and so CDs were far more
convenient in 1987 CDs outsold vinyl
records for the first time we almost
exclusively listened to CDs at the time
and vinyl we thought of it as like that
was an old people's thing the format hit
its lowest point in 2006 as iPods
music take over when I bought the
company in 2007 it was a much smaller
business we were 38 employees at the
time music lovers had nearly unlimited
options vinyl seemed dead nobody thought
vinyl was going to come back except for
the hardest of the hardcore but in the
early 2010s it did we could ask the
question why did that happen all of the
music that has ever been recorded is
available to almost all of us on our
phones there was something missing in
that experience the album isn't just
about the music the answer lies in the
way we express fandom I think a lot of
fans see buying things from their
favorite artists as keeping those
artists going meanwhile United watched
demand Skyrocket we grew to 90 to 100
people we went from running one and a
half shifts to three shifts we did
everything we could to accommodate the
growth it costs about the same as a
black t-shirt at a concert and less than
a hoodie and it contains the actual
music and beautiful graphics and
photography and lyrics and other stuff
and so for many fans especially young
ones that consider that to be a pretty
good trade Lincoln Park's 2023 reissue
of their album Meteora sold more than
three times as many vinyl copies as the
2020 reissue of Hybrid Theory the CD
sales of Hybrid Theory 20th anniversary
were around 13 000 ish the vinyl was
around 3000 ish and by the time we got
to meet you or two years later it
flip-flopped to jump from one format so
heavily weighted to the other is in a
couple years time is pretty substantial
and those substantial vinyl sales are
helping the artists bottom lines
on-demand streaming services like
Spotify and apple music and Amazon and
and so on are paying out something well
under a penny a stream artists are
making significantly more on a per unit
basis from record sales and it stands to
reason right I mean today a vinyl record
is going to cost somewhere between 25
and 30 dollars per disk and many fans
prefer the sound vinyl
there's more life to it it draws me in I
don't get tired of it I want to listen
to it more
[Music]
if I got a record at like a garage sale
or something and it's an actually it's
an old record with dust and scratches
and it's got that sound then to me it's
a really different experience while
vinyl is rebounding revenue from
physical formats made up just 11 of
recorded Revenue in 2022.
vinyl's continued growth isn't
guaranteed because records are really
hard to manufacture and most machines
are basically antiques these are some of
our Legacy landed presses again 50 to 60
years old and one of the challenges with
these presses is you know they break and
that can create a backlog for artists
and labels Lincoln Park is not like a a
fair comparison because the label does
prioritize our projects our wait time to
get the vinyl done was six months so I
have to imagine for a lot of other
artists it's a lot
slower that's very very difficult for an
independent artist or for an independent
label to schedule the manufacturing and
release of relatively small run of vinyl
with great Precision but the industry is
catching up new equipment is finally
being produced Mark just had 26 new
presses delivered from Sweden over the
last two years we've been putting this
together it's an 11 million dollar
project now United presses 60 in records
a day and has 234 employees
despite the challenges some industry
professionals think the format is here
to stay as long as there is demand for a
bespoke analog way for a consumer to
connect to an artist vinyl will continue
to be a significant and growing part of
the business
I don't know that it'll stick it'll beat
CDs or beat other formats forever but
for now at least people know that when
they're buying an album they love on
vinyl like they're buying it for a
reason it's a Keepsake it's a
collectible that's more the mentality
foreign
[Music]